[applause]
[music]
Glory to Ukraine to
thank you for the fact that we have
independence
six months of brutal full-scale war
8 years of heroic defense of our state
war in Donbas in the east of the state and a
generation of struggle for Ukraine I ask
you now to observe a minute of silence for
all Ukrainians  to all Ukrainians who gave
their lives for ours, please take a moment to honor it,
I would like it to
end sooner because I don't want mothers' tears, I
want children to wait for their fathers, for mothers to wait for their
sons to wait for
them to be victorious
[music]
what can be doubted if the whole country is
working  for this victory and we are standing here
thanks to those people who are not defending
[music]